[Music]
I'm really grateful to be here in Berlin
because the city gave me the chance to
realize my own projects and to have a
vision and maybe also realize something
that was not planned before so that's
why I'm here at the restaurant
[Music]
Federico testa comes from Bologna where
he was born in 1982 his father ran a
popular restaurant there for 35 years
when Federico came to Berlin his career
in the catering industry began rather by
chance in a restaurant called tabatha
because as a trained musician and
photographer
he actually had very different plans I
[Music]
came in Berlin in 2008 because I wanted
to play music with a friend of mine and
then things went completely different as
we planned and started to work as a
photographer and Francisca my friend a
chef and then together we started to
cook for friends and it became a
restaurant
after de Buffy closed Federico opened
his own restaurant Bosco in 2014 in
Berlin's hip courts back district he
lives nearby one of more than 4,000
Italians living in Kreuzberg
[Music]
before opening for business Federico
spent five months renovating the place
he did a lot of work himself his idea
was to create a modern and welcoming
atmosphere
[Music]
eating in Italy is a very important role
because around the table big decision
I've made and you can talk about every
topic on the table with a nice glass of
wine that makes everything softer and of
course also good food makes it
everything smooth the menu changes
regularly according to the season
Federico wants his guests to enjoy
traditional Italian food the kind he
enjoyed as a child
[Music]
tortelloni with ragout ricotta cheese
and spinach combines modern with
traditional cuisine the recipe for the
ragu prepared with vegetables and ground
beef comes from Bologna there it's
traditionally eaten with pasta total Oni
also come from northern Italy there is
similar to totally knee but are much
larger
[Music]
normally tortelloni are filled with
vegetables and served with the ragu
sauce
[Music]
the dish we presented today is a total
only with ragout filled with ricotta and
peanuts which is the rid original and we
made it upside down so fit with ragout
and with the cream of ricotta spinach
and to me reminds me really of my
Sundays and my Sundays at my grandma
because that was what she was always
cooking for me like fresh pasta is a
very simple recipe but it's well made
it's like heaven to begin with Federico
worked in the kitchen too but now he
devotes all of his time to being out
front catering to his customers
[Music]
Audio demo kuchi not over boy tortelloni
rapini ragù alla Bolognese Cory Cortez
Panaji bon appetito